you mind your work
and i will mind
mine rodrigo duterte was mayor of davao
city in the southern philippines for
more than 20 years he was catapulted
into the presidency by his ability to
convince millions of filipinos to rally
behind him
in office duterte quickly cemented his
role as an autocratic leader his war on
drugs was so violent that rights groups
believe at least 30 000 people have been
killed in police operations over the
last five years critics say he has used
state violence in ways not seen since
the martial law period under president
ferdinand marcus in the 1970s and 80s
duterte went after oligarchs but he also
jailed activists and members of the
opposition and shut down the country's
biggest media network and though he
promised that just a whiff of corruption
would be enough for him to fire
officials
years later most of those removed from
office have yet to face charges
he had to make deals with established
political forces so with that comes the
inability to sincerely push back against
institutionalized corruption the
president also hasn't revealed his own
wealth refusing to release an official
statement of assets liabilities and net
worth the first president to do so in
decades
when he was mayor he did not strengthen
he did not need a check and balance
because he was a king of davao city so
he didn't need to listen
to
a co-equal body the pandemic and the
recession it triggered are perhaps the
most challenging issues duterte has
faced but still many believe he deserves
credit for prioritizing large-scale
infrastructure projects
duterte made no secret of his admiration
for chinese president xi jinping and at
first he was so eager to be in china's
good graces that duterte cancelled a
defense agreement with the country's
strongest ally the united states a
decision he reversed just a few months
ago
as duterte enters his final days in
office he remains an enigma one of the
most polarizing but also one of the most
popular presidents ever elected in
recent philippine history
jamella allendogen al jazeera davao city
southern philippines
we saw richard heydarian uh who in uh
report there he's a political analyst
and associate professor at the
polytechnic university of the
philippines and he's with us now live uh
good to have you with us richard will
people in general uh be sad to see
duterte go are they better off now
than they were when he came to power
are we good folks i can't hear the
studio
hi richard can you hear me will people
be sad to see duterte go are they better
off now than when he came to power
now sorry richard can't hear me we'll
come back to richard in just a few
moments uh
bear with us
now tension is running high in the
indian state of rajasthan after a hindu
man was beheaded on tuesday the act was
posted online police have arrested two
people al jazeera's pavli mithal reports
hundreds of people take part in a
funeral procession for kanhayal
surrounded by security officials and tv
cameras they demand justice his wife
yashoda says she wants those responsible
held to account
we want justice and yes we want them to
be given the death penalty
authorities have arrested two men
accused of murdering lal in his
tailoring shop they are alleged to have
posted a video online and made threats
against prime minister narendra modi
according to media reports they're
accused of killing lal for supporting
nupur sharma a former spokeswoman of the
bjp party who was suspended for making
islamophobic comments
the incident has sparked tensions in
rajasthan state in western india
protests in the city of odepo turned
violent and shops were shut down a
curfew was imposed in several cities and
internet access was suspended across the
state
law and order is being maintained the
situation is peaceful
even after the murder there have been no
major incident in which anyone has died
the situation is completely under
control now
police say lal received many threats for
his social media posts and had sought
police protection
his wife told local media that he had
skipped work for days before his killing
investigators say they're treating his
killing as a case of terrorism parvital
jazeera new delhi
let's go back to richard heydarian then
in manila richard will people in general
be sad to see duterte go are they better
off now
than they were when he came to power
well that's a difficult question i mean
if you look at it quantitatively meaning
the popularity ratings of duterte is
going out as the most popular filipino
president if not one of the most popular
leaders ever i mean close to 80 approval
rating so that means vast majority of
filipinos seem to be satisfied with him
at the same time you know i think a lot
of filipinos are also
recognizing the fact that the country is
not necessarily in good place you have
two years of pandemic
five quarters of recession and the thing
with duterte really is that he's a
master of performative populism he knows
how to entertain people he knows how to
inspire people or instill fear but the
reality is if you look at duterte's
presidency yes there have been some
gains in terms of peace process in
mindanao some infrastructure development
some sort of pushing for independence
from the united states but overall his
presidency has been a bonfire of
institutions he has been very good in
undermining democratic institutions or
liberalism in the philippines but it has
not been a very effective statesman in
terms of creating a new order or a new
constitutional order altogether i wanted
to ask you more about that you mentioned
that the state of the country and and
whether after six years of duterte it is
actually better off in terms of its of
its wealth uh the rule of law and as you
you mentioned there that the state of
its institutions
right i mean in terms of the economy of
course duterte can make an excuse that
well you have the pandemic it's not my
fault but the reality is that the
philippine economy could have done way
better had it been under much more
effective leadership i mean the
philippines had close to 10 gdp
contraction in 2020 because of the
extended lockdowns and delayed response
by the government while some of our
neighbors like taiwan and vietnam even
had gdp growth in 2020 not to mention
china at the same time if you look at it
when it comes to foreign policy he asked
for more independence from u.s but at
the same time he was becoming more and
more dependent on china even russia to a
certain point before the invasion of
ukraine but really the real problem the
cross of the problem is the rule of law
president duterte ran on an anti-crime
anti-drug campaign and yet six years
into office we have no evidence
whatsoever ever to suggest that he has
had a sustained solution to this problem
what we know about are these thousands
of extrajudicial killings or allegations
of massive human rights abuse not to
mention shutting down right and left of
different independent media outlets and
those who have criticized the government
and president duterte throughout the
past few years so the rule of law
situation has dramatically deteriorated
in past few years even as the
philippines was of course never perfect
but duterte has also not shown any clear
gain long-term gain in terms of the war
on drugs where are the big fish that he
was talking about where's the uh
sustained solution to the drug problem
criminality in the country if you have
so many judicial killings and
unexplained deaths so how do you think
history will judge his presidency i
suppose it depends very much upon what
comes next
definitely i mean duterte is the best
thing that has happened to demarcuses uh
tomorrow i mean soon uh ferdinand marcos
jr will become the president of the
philippines next president of the
philippines and i think a huge part of
that is because duterte because one of
the big things that duterte did was to
complete the rehabilitation of the
marcosus and when his daughter sarah
duterte the incoming vice president
teamed up with uh freddie and marcus jr
it became an unbeatable team for the
opposition so in that sense he's one of
his biggest legacies will be the return
of the marcuses and let's see how people
were gonna judge the return of the
marcuses but for the foreseeable future
i expect duterte to remain a popular
leader for a lot of filipinos who just
wanted something different after decades
of dysfunctional politics and
half-hearted liberal reforms always good
to talk to you richard many thanks
indeed richard heydarian there in manila